the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
they don't have some of the uh diversity
in other states that we have in nevada
and that's created some of the problem
of getting people back to news
tonight on politics now nevada puts up
big money for vaccine incentives we'll
tell you who's eligible to get the
prizes
plus you could see um
[Music]
getting pot consumption lounges up and
running the head of nevada's cannabis
compliance board explains regulations
that still need to be written
and how he sees the state of the
industry right now and giving college
athletes the ability to make
money the new nevada law and testimony
of congress accusing the ncaa of abusive
behavior
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler
how do you convince everybody to get the
coronavirus vaccine
well the state of nevada thinks the
solution is cold hard cash
this week it announced a raffle with
five million dollars in prizes all for
getting inoculated
sasha loftus has the story 5
million reasons to get your covid19
vaccine
vaccine nevada days is a covet vaccine
incentive promotion
that will provide 5 million dollars in
cash and prizes
nevada has joined a list of other states
offering incentives for those who get
their shots
that would definitely make people want
to come out and get vaccinated some
love the idea while others are choosing
to hold off
just waiting just to see you know the
developments
with the science nevada's vaccination
numbers are still lagging behind other
states
that's why leaders are kicking things
into high gear
with vax nevada days we need to get
shots in arms to protect people as much
as possible
anyone who's had at least one dose will
be entered into a raffle to win cash
education savings plans state park
permits and fishing licenses
one lucky person will also win a grand
prize
of one million dollars every single
nevadan counts as we work to end this
pandemic
it's an idea many call inventive in the
rush to
return immunity i would have got
vaccinated anyway to stay safe and keep
my kids and my family safe but even
better
if i'm getting something extra for it
and they believe it will help us
inch even closer to community-wide
protection sasha loftis 8 news now
the prog the program is funded with
federal dollars not
nevada dollars the raffle will remain
anonymous
we do have more information if you're
interested eightnewsnow.com
nevada is working towards giving
tourists and locals
more places to smoke pot places in
general july
also marks four years of legal
recreational marijuana here in nevada
and one year of the cannabis compliance
board i spoke with the board's executive
director about
this industry and we started by talking
about the new pot lounges bill
so what will happen now is it it's not
going to happen right away or overnight
there is a significant amount of
regulatory work that needs to take place
um that'll take place through public
meetings and public workshops through
the cannabis advisory commission that's
assist their agency to the cannabis
compliance board
we've got to figure out things like air
quality and safety
and single-use products and
ready-to-consume products
um and so that'll take a number of
months through that we'll design the
licensing and application process
and so you know if everything goes well
and there's no kind of regulatory
setbacks we could see
maybe early late uh mid part of 2022
some consumption losses coming online
is it going to be a free fall for all is
there going to be some sort of a
restriction on how many lounges are
allowed what what
might it look like in the crystal ball
here of marijuana lounges
sure so the bill envisions uh two types
of
consumption lounges one is a retail
attach so that'd be a consumption lounge
attached to a current adult use retail
store
while that number is not limited per se
in the legislation
uh it is set up that if uh each owner
can only have one consumption lounge and
so if you own multiple dispensaries you
will only be able to open one
consumption lounge and that effectively
limits the number of
retail patch consumption monitors that
will come online
there are also things like uh capacity
concerns and some current
uh retail stores are not built for
consumption lounge
some may be in a strip mark where they
can't build a consumption lounge and so
that'll further limit the initial uh
number at least on the onset um the
second type of lounge envisioned in the
bill is an independent
lounge and so that uh that really could
be anything
um uh in
there's a a at least an initial cap on
that of 20
independent lounges 10 of which will be
held for social equity applicants
and so we'll see a smaller amount uh at
the start
uh however the board has the authority
in the bill to increase those amounts
uh certainly on the independent side as
we move forward
it's been about a year since the ccb
started
and it's been interesting to follow how
the marijuana industry in nevada has
been shifting whether it's not only
dispensaries but also with cultivation
what's been some of the bigger
challenges for the ccb in the last
year with trying to
get the marijuana industry in nevada
solidified and running smoothly
sure i mean well over the past year
obviously i mean we were tasked with
with creating a state agency from
from scratch uh we also had to pass over
you know 130 pages of regulations to get
this industry
um started we completely overhauled the
way we oversee
cannabis uh much more of a gaming
control board model and a gaming
oversight model which we did
throw in a global pandemic into that
equation
and um you know what we did during uh
the the the pandemic in kobet uh with
implementing curbside pickup
uh expanded delivery options and virtual
vehicle inspections
helped keep the industry uh afloat truly
on
on that side of things um throughout
kobe and so
um you know many challenges but but but
extremely happy with where we're at
and what we've done in this first year
as the
as the ccb with so much money in las
vegas
um what sort of enforcement or concerns
did the ccb have with
with regards to how financially
whether it's dispensaries or now when a
year or so pot lounges
operate making sure that the money
is that they make is being
is legitimate is being handled
legitimately
and isn't being weaved through casinos
or
there's nothing sort of illegal going on
is that part of what ccb would do
absolutely and that's what we look for
in our investigations and enforcement
side of things i mean
uh large-scale cash transactions are the
hallmark of money laundering right
so if you're in an industry like a
cash-based cannabis industry
all transactions are large based cash
transactions
and so it's it's a big concern for us
and it's what we
we we look out for on a daily basis
um you know hopefully we see some action
at the federal level with congress
um some of the banking legislations that
as out there it has
a bipartisan support if if we can get
some of that through that'll obviously
certainly
help us in the state with our regulation
and enforcement
and that was tyler klimas with the
cannabis compliance board the executive
director
meanwhile california's legal marijuana
industry is actually
struggling on monday the legislature
there voted to approve 100 million
dollars to basically bail out pot
growers and sellers
the money is earmarked to have cannabis
cultivators dispensaries and
manufacturers
transition from temporary licenses to
permanent ones
the governor of california his office
says 82 of their licenses
licensees are still on a temporary basis
back here in nevada governor steve
sisilak ended up vetoing four bills from
the legislative session
just before that veto deadline one bill
that he vetoed would have created a
legislative ethics commission
governor sysolak says several
commissions already tackle ethics
he says he vetoed a housing
discrimination law because it would make
people ineligible for certain federal
housing programs
that bill would have created tourism the
bill rather that would have created
tourism improvement districts
was also rejected the governor says its
mandate in that law to collect extra tax
information
would hurt restarting the economy and
finally a bill to create a state dental
committee was vetoed because the
governor says
it included exemptions of open meeting
laws
a measure that did pass the legislature
and was signed by the governor could
bring about a dozen new schools here to
clark county
33 other campuses at ccsd would be
renovated with this new funding
this week governor sisalek toured del
robison middle school near nellis in
that school is nearly 50 years old
there's peeling paint nicked tables
aging infrastructure well this overhaul
it's scheduled to take
10 years the governor though wants to
fast track it
these neighborhoods deserve better and
they don't deserve better eight years or
ten years from now
they deserve better now i don't want a
kid that's in
kindergarten to be the first one that's
going to be coming into these schools
i i want this done quickly this needs to
be prioritized
ccsd plans to bring forward project
proposals on this issue
as early as the fall a gun rights group
has filed a lawsuit against
nevada's new ban on ghost guns the new
law outlaws firearms with
no serial numbers litigation was filed
by the delaware-based
firearms policy coalition it claims the
law violates the second amendment by
being too broad
proponents of the ban say people who are
barred from owning guns
were able to get through the make it
yourself kits
get through the laws well the results
from boulder city and its election
are in matthew fox beat cokie booth for
the city council seat down there you see
their 52 to 48 percent of the vote
fox owns the fox smokehouse bakery by
two to one margin also voters in boulder
city approved spending seven million
dollars to build a new aquatic center
and approved a land sale that'll help
pay for part of that
the turnout in the boulder city election
34 and interestingly
2200 of the 3900 votes were by
mail and that's going to be an option
for all nevadans in elections
going forward next week clark county
sheriff joe lombardo is scheduled to
speak
at a nevada gun rights group meeting the
nevada firearms coalition is essentially
nevada's version of the nra
and it says lombardo will address the
second amendment
sheriff lombardo has said before he's
running for governor as a republican
however he has not held an official
kickoff event or put
out his platform closed but working on a
reopening
it's sad to see so many trees and the
turf
and just see it from the car as opposed
to being able to enter the space
next on politics now the city of las
vegas plans and timeline to reopen
huntred circle park
welcome back to politics now
this week a committee chaired by nevada
senator catherine cortez-masto held a
hearing over southern nevada's largest
lands bill ever among those who
testified jocelyn torres
senior field director for the
conservation lands foundation
having grown up in las vegas nevada the
ancestral lands of the southern paiute
people
you can imagine that there weren't a ton
of recreational activities for those of
us under 21
that is with the exception of our public
lands i spent countless hours hiking
camping and soaking in the sun with my
family and friends and annually made the
journey north to the ruby mountains for
a family hunting trip
so this bill protects 2 million acres of
public land in clark county for
conservation and recreation
it also sets aside 65 square miles for
affordable housing
projects and critics of this measure say
that land is just going to go to big
real estate investors
the bill though does have bipartisan
support including all of nevada's
delegation in congress democratic
senator jackie rosen is proposing a bill
aimed at reviving travel and tourism
it's the tourism act it makes
infrastructure investments
in those industries tourism that
includes paying for new transportation
methods like light rail
the bill passed out of the committee
that she chairs it's now headed to the
senate
floor huntred circle park near downtown
las vegas has been closed since 2018
but now the city is talking about what
it would take to finally reopen it
madison kimbra was at city hall this
week to learn what neighbors think of
the plans
we need recreation more than ever to
help in our restoration
and also most importantly build our
community at one point a staple in the
las vegas community
hunt ridge circle park has had its ups
and downs it was built in 1941 but has
since been closed the last few years
due to public safety concerns monday
night city leaders joined residents at
city hall to talk about improvements at
the park
and a timeline for reopening we're
looking at 18 to 24 month process
because we're going to have
continued meetings that we'll plan that
will the architect can
offer some renderings the community can
have some input
some of the amenities suggested
including building a dog park
gym stations community garden and a
gated fence with an access code
residents gave their feedback online
many who say they're just eager to get
this park
up and running again we moved to the
neighborhood a couple years ago
and we you know have been missing the
open space right it's sad to see
so many trees and the turf and just see
it from the car as opposed to being able
to
enter the space i'd like to see now that
people are coming
back out to associate with each other
it's made and built in a way that people
can interact with each other madison
kimbrough 8 news now
there will be several more meetings
before the park does reopen and that is
scheduled to reopen in 2023
and not far from huntred circle park
there is of course the huntridge theater
and plans to renovate the theater are
moving forward it's been closed since
2004 in the past it's hosted
lots of bands the killers chili peppers
etc
local real estate developer jay dapper
bought the historic venue earlier this
year
and his plan is to renovate it into that
over the next
three years letting college athletes
make money coming up next we'll talk
about a new nevada law aimed at letting
university
athletes profit off their image and the
push to make that a national law as well
you're watching politics now
recently nevada lawmakers passed a bill
to allow college athletes to profit off
their image
their name and their likeness it kicks
in january 1st
proponents say it's a matter of fairness
and that it helps all athletes
the bill also includes a study on the
issue
nevada was the 17th state to pass that
law now
congress is considering passing similar
legislation federally
other laws for college athletes protect
their rights to
proper health care but as alexander
limon explains the hearing on
experiences of college athletes
also detailed abuses and injustices
college athletes came to capitol hill
thursday asking lawmakers to set uniform
standards for college athlete
compensation
college sports has become a
multi-billion dollar business that has a
financial monopoly
over its commodified athletes less than
two percent of ncaa athletes go on to
play professionally
meaning that the best years for them to
monetize their name image and likeness
is these four years
the ncaa says it's in the process of
changing its rules to allow athletes to
profit off
endorsements christina chanel a former
captain of the ucla track and field team
told senators
the ncaa is riddled with other problems
these years could have been the best
years of my life but instead
they were overshadowed by injustice
trauma
and inequity athletes also said many of
them are forced to choose majors that
allow them to focus on sports
something that also impacts their
financial success later in life
athletes say too often schools aren't
looking out for athletes interests and
ignore cases of sexual assault and the
mental and physical health of athletes
martin mcnair's son jordan mcnair died
from heat stroke suffered during
practice
i can't get out of my mind the athletic
athletic trainer
on the field that day yelling if he
can't walk
drag his ass across the field states
like maryland and california passed new
laws to protect athletes
but athletes and even the ncaa say a
single set of federal rules would be
better
in washington alexandra limon
nine years ago this week the daca
program was created
it was intended as a temporary
protection for young immigrants
who arrived in the u.s illegally as
children nevada has had about 13
000 daca recipients our entire
congressional delegation
supports a bill to make those
protections permanent but
congress is once again struggling to
pass that democratic senator alex
padilla
and republican senator john cornyn want
to see permanent protections for those
dreamers
daca was enacted as a stop gap measure
it was never enough nor intended to be
enough
and in america we do not hold children
responsible for the actions of their
parents
joining us to talk about the future of
the daca program alexander limon joining
us from washington dc
uh alex there's a new version called the
2021 dream and promise act
how is it different from what's already
in place and talk about the opposition
as well
well congress has been trying to pass
versions of the dream act for 20
years now and that those attempts do
have
bipartisan support some republicans say
they support the idea of providing
permanent protections
for these young immigrants who came to
the u.s
illegally as children however the 2021
version
republicans say just goes too far for
their comfort because
it also provides protections to
other types of undocumented or actually
they're not undocumented to other types
of immigrants
tps recipients for example tps
stands for temporary protected status
and they were given those permits to
come to the u.s you know sometimes
some of them have been here for 20 years
as well
uh because of devastating natural
disasters in their home countries things
like that so
this year's version of the dream act
does include protections
for those immigrants as well and so
republican senators like john cornyn who
have expressed support for
uh the dream act in the past say this
version won't get through the senate but
it's worth noting that previous versions
that didn't include that
didn't get approved by congress either
there's a federal court case in texas
still pending
it could have an effect certainly on how
daca moves forward and how this issue is
taken up
elsewhere around the country can you
explore a little bit more about what
this
case is and how it affects national
discussions
sure while i mentioned that some
republicans do say that they support
daca recipients and support the idea of
giving them permanent protections
other republicans both here in
washington in congress and around the
country do not
for example state legislators in the
state of texas the texas attorney
general
was joined by eight other states in
bringing this lawsuit
two or three years ago now it's still in
the works but the lawsuit
alleges that daca recipients and the
daca program have
cost these states irreparable damages
because these states have had to pay for
things like health care and education
of the daca recipients and so they are
attempting to strike down and get rid of
the
daca program all together nationwide
alex simone from washington d.c there is
no date
yet on when we could expect a ruling on
that case in texas
this week in what to watch fundraising
is really starting to pick up for
campaigns
county commissioner ross miller has a
fundraiser scheduled at the cosmopolitan
five thousand dollars per couple now
you'll remember miller just got elected
to the county commission last year in
fact it was a supreme court hearing
in the state supreme court to affirm his
position on the county commission that
just was ruled upon fundraising is
working way ahead of when he is up
in 2024. so that is what we are watching
for this upcoming week there's a lot of
other
potential announcements coming as well
so we'll certainly have that for you
right here on politics now next week but
for now we thank you very much for
watching for all the latest political
news
head to eight newsnow dot com we're back
with you next saturday thanks for
[Music]
watching
[Music]
you